did you ever think you would make it I
feel I'm tastet Victory I know this life
for
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value Tam giv values
contagious this world of entrepreneurs
we get no value to haters how run homie
look what I become I'm the I'm the
one I don't give a damn you know all
right so what do we today's what episode
3:30 oh my God uh we got a bunch of
stories to go through here today by the
way what I do want to show is the
interview with uh Crown Prince resa is
going to be going out uh uh tomorrow
most likely Saturday we do have the
intro that I'm intro is I'm you the
sneak peek of the intro and I think
people are going to be blown away by
this cannot wait to get this this should
be one of those things that um not only
the Iranian Community Rob I'm going to
send this to you as well if you uh let
me check to see if I can send it to you
anyways uh if you get it I'd love to
show to the audience uh aside from that
let me just kind of give you an idea
what we're going to go through on
stories today Elon Musk had a rough uh
couple days this week because uh he he
tweeted something that he agreed with
somebody and the next thing you know
Facebook
co-founder uh tells him to
resign absolutely to resign uh with what
he actually said tap Tesla investor
ditches uh Tesla to go to rivan and then
all these other issues IBM pulls out of
ads from X there just a lot of stuff
going on uh you got to give him props
for the fact that at least he's straight
up saying what he believes in but that
doesn't mean capitalism is not going to
decide and say we're going to move our
money elsewhere Dana White told a
sponsor to go f themselves and uh we had
a meeting with him a couple weeks ago
where he told the story to us and we
kind of know what the sponsors he
doesn't reveal the name and so we won
either but it's very interesting what
happened there with that story and then
in the middle of a thean tells him about
what happened with pelaton you should
see what Dana does right in the middle
of the interview when he this is why the
market loves and Trust the man Dana
White this is why he's the best
commissioner in sports today when his
career is over with he's going to go
down as one of the greatest
commissioners of all time some may even
make the argument as the best
Commissioner of all time in sports stoop
dog said he's giving up smoking smoking
weed and it was insane when he said that
the question is do you believe it do you
not believe it we'll talk about that
today uh I know Kevin Hart said one
thing one time he said there's only two
people I'll smoke weed with he said I've
never smoking weed but if there's two
people I run into one of them was uh I
think he said Marley the other one is
Snoop if I go meet them you have to
smoke weed you're going to do do those
guys I guess that option is gone for
heart uh if Snoop is no longer doing it
YouTube debuts AI tool that mimics
vocals of artists like John Legend Demi
Lavado to make songs talk about Ai and
creating words and all of that creating
a that's pretty interesting when you
think about how that can threat your
phone your phone picks up stuff okay um
survey from West Bank comes out uh that
majority of the people in West Bank
support the October 7th Massacre very
interesting American Express report for
Osama Bin Laden after reading viral uh
letter by the way Americans express not
American Express Americans express I
don't want people to be like American
Express support holy no no Americans
express FBI Dig's bodies possibly buried
by Gambino family in Upstate New York
huh that's surprising hey how you
doing no sympathy left compa compassion
fatigue can happen to anyone here's how
to overcome it that's just such a funny
story I want to talk about you
compassion fatigue honestly there is
compassion fatigue after Co 100% how you
doing how you doing I'm doing good and
then how you doing how you doing how you
doing Tio loves that I love it company
behind the Miss Universe files for
bankruptcy after accepting transgender
contestant we have an idea for these
guys thought though that's weird Absolut
an Bush's marketing Chief finally exits
after the Dillan mvin Fiasco Target
stock surges as earnings overshadow
sales decline uh China's home prices
plunge the plums the most in eight years
and a soccer star Megan rapo claims
injury and championship game is proof
God doesn't exist I can't wait to talk
about that in the lasto that was what
rapo rap whatever that's how I pronounce
it I'm that's fine I'm just more new
breed of supercomputer aims for the two
quintilian Mark uh which is a
supercomputer that came out out a wsj
story Rob do you have the clip for cr r
pal that I texted you if you do have it
uh if you can just uh upload it to your
uh to your deal uh um yeah I wanted to
show okay before you do that let's go
into a couple of the stories here so
let's start off
with uh which one do we start off with
let's start off with uh do you want to
go to Universe do you want to go to
Let's actually start off with uh Snoop
Dog saying he's given up smoking Daily
Mail story snoop snoop aoop okay comes
out and
announces he is done smoking weed
surprises finds by declar I'm giving up
smoke in a recent post followed by a uh
more elaborate statement after much
consideration from my f with my family
I've decided to give up smoke he also
urged others to respect my privacy at
this time despite snoop's announcement
many fans remain doubtful with some
speculating it might be promotional
stunt related to potential business
ventures in the Edibles industry notably
Snoop Dog who was previously rumored to
have uh someone roll 70 75 to 150 joints
for him daily revealed the shift in his
cannabis consumption habits earlier this
year stating being a grandfather has
changed me in multiple ways do you
really think he's going to give up
smoking weed Snoop bro sipping on Jin
and jeice stop it all right look we all
grow up with Snoop okay Dr Dre and Snoop
back in the day Compton doing his thing
ain't nothing but a G thing baby Snoop
you don't you can't just spend your
entire life smoking weed and then hit us
with I sto smoking weed and the standard
please respect me and my family's
privacy at this time challeng like this
like there was a death in the please
respect my privacy this time buddy you
built your entire freaking brand on weed
and now you want us to be like good for
Snoop it's been about time sure buddy
dude just double down on what you do
stop it yeah and the the funny thing to
me is where it goes after much
consideration with my family like did
they all sit down like at at like the
like the dining room table they're like
listen today's the day I'm done with the
weed even the kids are like air dropping
into your computer you know I covered
the story this is like maybe a year ago
this guy this guy is rumored to have
someone that to roll 75 to 150 joints
for him a day by the way he paid him
like 80 grand a year just to be his weed
roller that guy's fing whatever the
number was fing let me Rob run a poll if
people actually believe he's going to
quit smoking or it's a stunt just type
in he is quit smoking it's a publicity
stunt I'm curious you know what people
think Tom I'm thinking I'm I'm going to
be the first vote publicity stunt and be
respect my privacy at this time is like
baiting baiting the media to come attack
you baiting them to come after and ask
more questions about it I think it's a
publicity stud is going to Edibles and
here's the case study I give you chich
and Chong anybody remember chich and
Chong comedy they had an album called
the Big Bamboo where you pulled the the
record out of the sleeve and there's
this giant rolling paper in there and Up
In Smoke smoke that was their big thing
they were all about smoke cheich Marin
and Tommy Chong well what have you been
doing for the past 3 years they've been
pushing their Edibles you can see them
they pop up on Twitter every day I'm on
Twitter I see their stuff they're Ed
there you go and by the way they're not
and by the way I think whoever's doing
their social media marketing isn't
really targeting it because it's just
being like spammed everywhere it's just
showing up and I'm the wrong customer by
the way what I'm hearing is that they're
doing very well and so if there's one
thing that Snoop is is an entrepreneur
and a capitalist underneath all this and
I think he's looked across the aisle and
he's seen what's about to happen to
vaping and I think he's got something
coming so you think he's still going to
be rolling down the street smoking in
those siping on J I think I think he's
still going to be smoking and this is
part of a publicity stunt standby for
Edibles for his Market the same way
chich and push you hit you know as I
famously say the nail on the head you
definitely hit the nail on the head that
be down the street smoking I got my mind
and my money and the money of my mind
this is a complete money I think it's a
money play cuz just the other day like
think about it who who is Snoop Dog
Snoop Dog is a gangster from California
right like like legitimate gangster
Sayang about he he is he is he a or
what what what what gang is he
Affiliated long Be Long Beach guess
I'm to talk about I'm at Target and I
look and he I see a snoop display he's
selling wine at Target oh yeah you want
to talk about from gangster to if you're
like what's the name of the wine what's
the name of wine what's the name of the
wine what what is it called 19 crimes 19
crimes blood and it's blood red wi blood
red we you remember when remember when
IHOP like three or four years ago came
out and they said guys we changed our
name and it's now ihob it's the
International House of burgers remember
that and they did it for a week and it
turned out it was a marketing stunt just
to tell people listen we got Burgers now
but we're still IHOP brilliant we're
still doing pancakes out here baby
there's a marketing play here
which is good when the Smoke's too harsh
he's going to come out and say this
listen guys what percentage do you think
but here's my newest prob check this out
what what percentage you think it's real
percentage what percentage you think
zero 2.5% Z like 0% oh you're
serious unless unless I'll give I'll
give it 2% I'll give it 25 because you
know why P what if God forbid like he
has something wrong like what if cancer
or something it's real and he does it he
he will be like the ultimate guy that'll
force a lot of other people to quit
smoking like if the if no he will though
but you have to realize because Stephen
A talked about it and he posted
something about it but if he does he's
going to cause a lot of other people to
question smoking weed and he can if he
goes on a tour talking about why he quit
smoking and encouraging others your
grandfather but it's a different phase
of your life so you may be going through
it but I'm more 8020 85 15 is where I'm
at that uh that it's 80 that he's still
going to smoke 20 that he won't yeah
that's right that nobody's talking about
it what if God forbid there's something
physically wrong how much weed can you
smoke without getting something wrong
that's my 2% like if he's going to his
doctor doctor says hey man you got a
spot on your lungs and he's a
grandfather 7526 they think it's a
publicity SP stunt
26% people haveen 19 crimes
edible the air drop finally worked Rob I
think you got the clip here's the intro
I want to show you about the interview
with Crown Prince that's going to be
going out the Iranian Community brace
for impact this is going out most likely
tomorrow uh go ahead and play
it your father was right he was doing
the right things he made IR ran a better
place
unfortunately the competitors notice he
was getting
stronger and he revealed his hand
instead of maybe holding his
hand and I kind of pissed off the
enemy I think mistakes were made on
every front including my own father
inflation right now is 45% interest
rates
12% some will say there's a business
model for the Middle East
being
chaotic
at some point it's got to
give what can happen after we eliminate
this Mafia likee regime that uses
repression at home and aggression
abroad what they fear are the people
more than
anything what gives us the incentive is
we deserve better than what we have
right now Iran should have been today
the Japan of the Middle East
I mean what I say when we can move from
Hope to believe because I believe all
the ingredients for that exist both
internally and
abroad do you want the
chop wow Pat let me explain something to
you I I have to see that I I can't wait
to watch it myself and I I can't wait to
I'm telling you I can't wait to see it
because you know to you you you you know
your family Iran my f I live there so to
me I can't wait for this to come out uh
for the world to see it's the first time
he's ever done a three-hour long form
interview like this ever and you said
it's one of your top uh interviews it's
one of my favorite conversations of all
time I mean I'm if moving forward this
has to be one of my top three to five
favorite conversations of all after I
watch it it may be a top two of all time
I really enjoyed this this was a yeah
how long were you working on this for
for it to come to fruition I mean first
meeting we had was March March 10th of
2015 in DC oh you've been working on
this for over we had a 3 4our meeting
there oh yeah yeah we had a 3 4our
meeting in DC and we've been working on
this for eight years why now why did he
agree to it now why now why me why not
why me yeah watch
uh uh why now because um it it's it's
messy it's ugly it's nasty what's going
on in the Middle East and he is by far
the best spokesperson that can give
insight on what's going on perspective
on what happened the cause his father
his connection he's been studying this
for his entire life who can speak better
on the JFK and the RFK assassination
better than RFK Jr nobody he is it you
want to know what happened to the
assassination talk to the son who went
14 years pain drugs when he saw his dad
getting assassinated his dad's about to
be a president no one has studied that
topic more than him so the closest
comparison I can get by the way CBS
interviews his father in 1976 and they
say say uh uh your majesty you are
currently possibly the most powerful man
in the world that's his father you
talking about somebody that 50 years ago
the world feared because they thought
this guy was going to take over the
world and he was on track to do so so
it's a very very interesting interview
and and Pat not to cut you off it's
going to be translated to be translated
in farsy as well so you can watch it in
fary or you can watch it in English Okay
sick all right let's go to the next
story here Dana White Rob if you got the
Dana White and the theovon clip if you
can play the first one Dana White talks
about what a sponsor asked him to do and
he breaks down what he ended up telling
him and he was very diplomatic about it
go ahead and play it me too this this
happened to me I posted a video for
Trump right on my personal social media
and one of our big sponsors called and
said take that down you know what I said
go
yourself you vote for whoever you want
to vote for and I'll vote for whoever I
want to vote for that's how this works I
don't even care who you're voting for
it's none of my business but
you yeah don't ever call me
and tell me who to vote for yeah very I
think a lot of people feel in fear these
days you know a lot of people feel in
fear that if they don't vote for certain
people they're going to lose their jobs
I mean it's Hollywood for example think
about how crazy that is it
sounds insane it sounds just like well
it'll keep happening unless more people
stand up for themselves there you go and
give them the you response okay so
now play the the1 clip which which first
of all I love did
and he told us a story in his office
when we were with him for a couple hours
it's a very this is why I respect the
guy this is why I respect the guy you
play this clip this is now Theon talking
about what happened with pelaton a
company call or a couple companies call
advertisers like you guys need to take
the episode Down you know what sponsor
did it oh pelaton was The Paton yeah
what do they sell bik the
stationary bikes yeah dude pelaton sell
stationary bikes and they got a problem
with Robert Kennedy yeah
you pelaton what who the are they
yeah right are you kidding me
yeah yeah pelaton calling patons
in the gym are those
pelaton asort no no there's bikes next
to it asport ask yeah we're getting rid
of
them we're getting rid of the Pelon a
company call or so P just to give people
a little context uh uh he he posted Theo
posted the video of RFK Pelon called and
said take it off of YouTube and then
that's the conversation that happened so
it's but Pat it's weird though but if
you have money and you're powerful you
could say like this but the average
person that's just out there trying to
make it you can't you can't but let me
tell you though but let me tell you
though he's empowering everybody no you
can't say that so the the average person
you're right when you're saying the
average guy that's taking $200 $300 $500
$400 but here's what happens this is why
I said if Snoop quits smoking weed he's
the big do when you think about smoking
weed living who's the who's the god of
smoking weed living obviously so if he
quits he can influence hundreds of
thousands of people to consider smoking
we okay if if Dana calls out Brands like
that guess what brands are now doing
they're sitting this hurt pelaton right
now listening to this and by the
way the fact that he doesn't reveal the
name of the other company he's talking
about I guarantee you there's an element
of it where he is hanging on to it for
future purposes that in case if he
does and I wouldn't be surprised if in
the next couple months he actually tells
people who it is the other brand but the
point here is this this is empowering
content creators to not allow sponsors
to bully you period so by the way okay
let's just say you are having a
sponsorship and you do support whatever
you support and sponsor calls you and
takes you tells you to take it down or
else yeah you should talk about it oh
100% and meaning I would take it down
but what do you say about the people
that Pat need this money need this
income and then all of a sudden they're
like
you sound is that
noise what sound is that somebody
drilling is somebody drilling I'll take
care I I just actually found out they
removing the pelaton from the gym that
we have here let's get that out of
here Rob so my point I I'm with you 100%
but what I'm saying is Pat the average
Joe that's has one sponsor that's giving
him $1,000 a month that he needs to pay
for food in his car and stuff they go
hey take it down that guy's taking it
down I mean I would hope for him to be
able like to say to have the power to
say f you and find somebody else but if
that's all you have then you're kind of
screwed aren't you hang on I have I have
another
perspective what did he say my personal
account yeah I put a a simple post about
voting for Trump a candidate so what
what Dana is talking about there he's a
business owner who has a enough of a
visibility and there's a lot of business
owners that have basic visibility you
could have a small business in your town
and have a Twitter with with 2,000
followers but people in your circle in
your small town see you and what he's
saying is I personally are voting this
way I don't care who you're voting for
that's not really not my business and
he's talking about I believe freedom and
a core point of free speech more than
he's talking about sponsorship defense
and I applaud Dana for saying it to
empower even the smallest businessman
who says hey I support this candidate I
like what he stands for here and not to
have other people come silence you
attempt to leverage any part of your
economic being like your sponsorships or
doing business with you I applaud this
for empowering all of us by by the way
here's a question for you you think
Dana's been like this since he was small
or you think Dana only started being
like this when he was big from
everything that I've seen from Dana Dana
has never changed that's the point so
the point is true this a philosophy by
by the way I'm telling you I can tell
you stories of me making a decision like
this that almost cost me a few hundred
million doll okay I'm telling you story
about me sitting in a room with moral
Tom and moral Amore and a AIG sitting
there and the concern was about me being
AR because insurance fraud and I said if
this is what you're going to do we're
going to have a problem if they still
dropped us I don't have the kind of
money they have to pay $1,200 lawyers at
that face of my life phase of my life I
could only afford $300 or $400 an hour
lawyers they can afford $1,200 $1,500 an
hour lawyers if we lose that in that
moment but I will tell you that moment
was the moment the insurance industry
found out these guys are not playing
around period Tom and I on a call one
time okay Tom if if you're comfortable
telling the story we'll tell the story
you know which one I'm talking about I
want to hear it Tom up in the
mountains when we're smoking we Tom were
you on that Che Tom were you on that Che
different the one in the jacuzzi because
there's a couple big conversations we
had one the jacuz that one that one is
our business it's no one's business the
one I'm talking about is I know which
one we're sitting in in the truck we're
having a call yeah no I'm talking about
uh the call when this company comes to
to us and they want they want us to pay
$25,000 do you remember that call I am
perfectly comfortable with this okay do
you mind sharing that story by the way
Tom had just started it we we we haven't
worked with each other for years yet
okay this is maybe nine months we're
working together you too me and Tom got
actually it's probably even less than N9
months something like that but go ahead
Tom so we had a um I'll just put it this
way um in um insurance you have a lot of
software out there that that helps you
do this or that let's just call it
helper software that does some function
and it saves you money saves you a head
count and it works real well we had gone
to an insurance conference long story
short found some software that was
really really applicable for what we
could do could save us some money help
us process things faster all businesses
want to go a little faster process more
a lower cost all that help us do that so
the guy's really nice guy actually the
the CEO standup guy but at the end of it
he said
hey here's the price for it and you know
you have a couple other insurance
carriers you work with that if you'll
call them and tell them how much you
like the software and they're using it
on the other side of your business it'll
help me cut a deal with them and then
I'll I'll be working with all the
carriers you understand what he's saying
yeah yeah he's saying hey why don't you
call on behalf of you and and tell them
to use my software and you you have
influence so call him and get him to use
my software I'm like okay go ahead and
then then he says but I'd still like you
to pay you know to to to pay a license
fee to use the software and on the
surface I was thinking for a second okay
seems reasonable but then Pat said wait
a minute Tom if we are doing the
marketing and we're going to be the
salesman we should get a like almost
like a commission so why don't we get
the software for zero as our commission
for helping him of course that's that's
a no-brainer and that was that's
basically how long did that call last
with them uh 4 minutes 13 seconds that's
how I got on the call I say hey can I
ask you a question who do you think I am
you think I started selling yesterday
what do you think I do you think you
think I'm just one of these guys you can
get on a call and ask for a check and
I'm going to wire to you are you out of
your mind I said I'm paying you zero and
if you ask for it I will never call
anybody for this again period you know
what happens we get I said I'm done I
don't have nothing else to say I hang up
respectfully we hang up we're done Tom
is looking at me moral this is what
Mor's reaction is cuz moral at this
point has been working with me for years
Mor's like this just another Tuesday
would Pat okay what's going on Som just
walks I got to go to my next meeting
Tom's like WTF just happened what the
this all about then he calls Tom the guy
they get on the phone together the guy's
like Tom what was that about I mean I
thought this was going to be a civil
conversation you know what happens
afterwards that guy gets a call put your
phone aside guys they keep they keep
picking up the sound with the phone he
he he gets a call from from a guy saying
hey we are looking for insurance
companies to invest in okay and he says
is there any company you think we should
invest and he says there's this one
company that's ran by a guy that's very
crazy but I think you ought to consider
do you remember this y he tells him that
guy calls us meets with Tom that guy
brings us $10 million what with De La
Hoya with Gabrielle brener and the guy
that I had a four-minute call with the
software owner the software owner ends
up becoming one of the investors as well
wow because he understand by the way you
know what happened we made him a ton of
money with the investment and his
software and his company company ended
up exploding for them but but that's the
part that sometimes you think AA just
started being like this when he made
money but a guy like Dana's I promise
you Dana's been like this since he was
16 years old in the streets of Boston
Dana was like that pushing his Waiter on
saying I'm not going to stand up for
this when he lost a lot of things and
Dana having a position like this I
guarantee it's cost him a couple
relationships I guarant to you but
that's exactly what build A1 billion
brand you got to tip your 100% Pat so so
so going back to it by the way it ended
up being a great relationship we
friendship till today we got the
software at a at at a massive discount
practically free and we did make those
phone calls and we did help them and so
everybody won at the end of the day and
it's kind of interesting like especially
with the Dana thing it's like you're
going to hit him up about the
relationship or post about Trump he's
obviously one of the biggest most
visible supporters of Donald Trump I
mean look at every UFC he walks out with
the freaking guy it's kind of weird that
somebody would ask like hey take down a
post about supporting him it's like
don't you know who the hell Dana is you
knew who he was when he walked in the
door and when he signed up for the deal
you know that 100% yes like so to tell
him to tell him of all people to take it
down it's like that's I will say that
the the the the whole concept of telling
somebody what they can and can't do or
who you should or shouldn't vote for is
antithetical to the United States yeah
like this is what we do now you could at
the same time you could say I think
you're an idiot for voting for that
person I can't believe you did that
you're whatever whatever it is you could
say whatever you want but Adam this was
happening this was happening during Co
everywhere I agree this was happening
everywhere so any let's go to the next
story let's go to the it does come down
to Trump though what do you mean meaning
like nobody's saying don't vote for
Nikki Haley or else I'm sorry what are
you talking about no no no I'm sorry
theovon was for RFK yeah it's not it's
not it's not Trump theovon was RFK Adam
I think it's cancel culture Adam
everybody familiar with that I'm saying
Trump is the tip of the spear in this I
don't think that's not it though Adam
it's whoever is anti-establishment RFK
is anti Trump is anti trust me anybody
that is on the right that's going to be
anti-establishment or the left which is
RFK even if it's a mansion they're going
to say take it down anything that's
against whatever their Protocols are is
going to be taken down this is why when
we talked about the rock yesterday rock
is part of the establishment I was just
going to go to the Rock the point he's
not going to do anything to lose the
sponsor because those guys fear losing
sponsors they don't have Dana back
stand what R tried to do to VC he's not
establishment he's not part of the river
this what R I'll give you let me just go
to this let me just go to this anheiser
Bush's marketing Chief to finally exit
after budlight Dylan malvan Fiasco this
is a New York Post story their Chief
marketing officer Beno Garb is set to
resign at the end of the year citing a
new chapter in his career Kyle
Norrington the chief um commercial
officer will take over garbs role in
2024 can you pull up who Cal Norrington
is uh I want to know who that guys the
budlight campaign featuring transgender
influencer Dillan malany led to
significant sales decline budlight
losses top selling beer position to
Mexican import Modelo us revenue for the
company fell nearly 14% from July
through September and budl lights volume
and and dollar sales plummeted by 30 uh
uh 30% and 26.9% respectively despite
these challenges anheiser Bush remains
hopeful that about Bud Lights hopeful
about Bud Lights recovery whatever over
40% of laps budl customers expressing
willingness to give the brand another
chance here's why they're going to give
him another chance okay is this the co
not him Rob the the chief commercial
officers who I want you to pull up the
guy that just I read here Kyle
Norrington if you can look up Kyle
Norrington is that can you zoom in let's
read his profile and maybe if he can go
on his LinkedIn that'd be great uh Kyle
Norrington uh um this is going to be the
new guy Pat that's KY Norrington is the
chief commercial officer that's being
promoted to the chief marketing officer
effective 1 and I would love to know
what this guy's background is right
there to the left yeah so okay they
don't have the LinkedIn K overse sales
and marketing us continuous results
Innovative strategies and disruptive
ideas during his time as president of
Canada K developed and implemented the
Canada 10 YP resulting in a gain of a
full share point uh in 2020 he's also
step change the Beyond beer portfolio
and perform I want to know his
background through Innovation organic
growth and strategic Acquisitions like
Nutri vodka soda prior to that he was uh
oversaw Global brands at AB and inbev
and including Budweiser Stella uh uh uh
artoy and Corona can you go to all those
pictures just real quick Rob just scroll
down go start from the top and just go
fast all the way
down okay b b keep going keep going just
keep going they're all white yeah I'm
just saying this is 99% white men that's
100 basically
guys give
morrio but ESG Dei scores Limited at
best but they're going to double down
on guys guys but then it's like it's
like but by the way it's not it doesn't
take a genius for like marketing and
it's like you stick with what works Bud
Light has always been America and beer
and cowboys and this the whole
transgender the the pushing on on the
public has not working Pat how many how
many examples case studies have to
happen and we have another story coming
up later about it it's like when is
enough enough Tom when are people going
to stop trying to like bow down to this
small minority group and just say guys
we're sticking with what works I I think
take a look here Kyle Norrington is a
build and acquisition guy this guy
builds the brand he's acquired things
he's the business that's that's the guy
that got fired Ben w g of course he is
I'm just letting you that's who you're
looking at right there but Kyle
Norrington is at yeah and this is the
guy that got fired yeah Ben w yeah I'm
talking about Kyle Norrington and the
picture up here happens to be B my
Gar so what Brendan is doing I think is
damn smart he's saying you know what
enough with the marketing and all of the
stuff that has got us into trouble and
this experimentation and walk in the
plank on this I want to put in here
leading the marketing you know what I'm
going to put Kyle in here Kyle has
bought Brands built Brands he's been the
business and Commercial side of it do
you see the difference rather than the
pure fluff of marketing and you spend
and you do Super Bowl ads and you get
awarded for Super Bowl ads Sergio o
zimon was the CMO of coke um and he did
the famous Mean Joe Green commercial it
goes back to the 70s where he throws the
Jersey to the young kid but then he
looked at it it wasn't causing Coke to
sell and Z he said out with the campaign
everybody in marketing part oh we were
winning awards for this doing for that
he says you missed it the purpose of
marketing is to help sales sell stuff on
a measured basis
boom and so I think what's happening at
uh Budweiser I think they've taken a
look at things inside and I want to look
at the case study on this a year from
now two years from now and see what's
happened here because I think this is a
good move by Budweiser putting the
commercial guy in place and taking a
traditional marketing guy and the staff
and saying CU remember the girl that did
this and her supervisor I think both of
them are already gone by the way for
what it's worth for what it's worth this
guy Beno who was getting fired yeah uh
he was the former Chief strategy officer
at anheiser Bush she's only been there
for three years okay prior to that he
was at a he was a senior partner at Asia
Regional lead profit and then he was
there for two uh uh three years and
prior to that he was on caner Consulting
for 10 years head of Greater China
region and prior to that he was a
strategic planner at this W pnba
fellowship program and he's a graduate
of Harvard and a new guy Norrington went
to Stanford and he got his NBA from
Stanford in
marketing where this guy got it from
Harvard so I don't know what that means
about anything I will tell you this I
look at what dington has done according
to when it comes down to Brands and it
comes down to
teams what is a brand actually ask
yourself the question what is a brand
okay so when you think about Fox I'm
going to give you a brand and give me a
name okay Fox
News Roger ALS okay who else good you're
right Tucker I still think of Tucker who
else
Gutfeld oh Riley when you think about
who Hannity built that company yeah
what's the no it's the family it's murd
Murdo Mur when you think about ESPN what
name comes to mind Stephen A Smith when
you think about uh I don't know Apple
what name comes to mind Tim Cook Steve
Jobs Tim Cook Steve Jobs okay so you you
have to keep in mind that a company
today is not the company of what it was
20 years ago the company today is the
leadership team that company has mhm so
that company will get criticized based
on today's leadership team but that
company can change their reputation if
they change their company's leadership
team and the first person you got to
Fire and move on with is the person that
approved this when I met with the CEO of
anheiser bush and we were in uh uh UFC
in Vegas I'm having a conversation with
we spoke to him for he spoke to for like
10 minutes and I said I said who made
the decision did you know this campaign
was going out as a CEO do you not know
that they're doing this with with him
did the CMO know I know the girl that
did it was a VP or director but
shouldn't the CMO prove that and if a
campaign like this is going out do you
need to prove it or is it somebody say
where the company is so big that you
don't have access to because I
understand it's a massive company I
would probably say he didn't know the
CEO the company didn't know that they're
sending this to Dy Moi I think the CMO
knew that they were doing it I don't
think he knew mhm so they lost $30
billion that girl has let go the CMO has
let go the new person's coming on board
that's how you change a company's
reputation and if next year after the
multi whatever ninef figure deal you do
with UFC the only company that can save
you if you do that deal with them and
that decision doesn't bring numbers back
up and you make another stupid decision
like Dylan malany again guess what then
you need to be fired but the co left at
anheiser Bush has one year the only year
he's got left to prove his job is 2024
if he doesn't turn it around 2024 he's
fired by q1 of 2025 my prediction I
could be wrong go ahead Adam I just want
to add one more thing cuz we sort of
glossed over this that budlight lost
their top position number one beer in
America to who Modello a Mexican beer
company which by the way model
absolutely sucks it's one of the worst
beers I've ever had in my life I know
some people like it it's terrible I
think there's a deeper uh issue here a
deeper fissure of what's going on in
America you're telling me that America
the number one America has been replaced
by a Mexican beer we talk about all the
time the decline in American values The
Wall Street Journal about less religion
less patriotism less American Service
less religion just less American values
and this might be a stretch but I
actually think it's kind of spoton is
that now we're you know they say that
countries crumble from the inside and
everything that's going on with wokeness
and Dei and ESG and Dylan Mulaney
there's something to be said here that
Bud Light America
Clydesdales what up is being is being
replaced by freaking a Mexican beer
Modelo and it comes down to I thought
you were going to go to the fact that
Modell is a Mexican company they should
pay for the wall I thought that's where
you were going they should pay for my
beard going to but and it comes it comes
back to and you said the woke like the
going woke being BR broke is anybody
paying attention in these companies like
are you not seeing the writing on the
wall it doesn't work Pat what what's the
other story that you have about the the
pageant the Miss Universe you want to go
to that let's go Pat if you think about
remember the the the tie Trend she's
like this is a company for women let's
go to that let's that yeah let's go go
ahead touch it pat all right here we go
Miss Universe judge reveals bankruptcy
likely due to outrage over transgender
organizer so here we go they are about
to file bankruptcy a 2022 Miss Universe
Judge Emily Austin and suggest that the
bankruptcy of Miss Universe organizer
partly due to controversy uh surrounding
its transgender owner and
jackp who brought who bought the
organization for $20 million in 2022
Austin argues I think the outrage are
about a transwoman coming to Miss
Universe couldn't be more of an oxymoron
socially and morally is just wrong Emily
Austin argues that transgender women
should not be allowed to compete in
pageants like Miss Universe stating that
the opposite of of women's empowerment
she believes contestants like experience
life experiences should align with their
gender identity and criticizes
transgender women for not having a true
women's feminine story when when are
they going to look Pat think about the
name of of Miss Universe what's the
first word in it Miss Miss and it's like
I don't understand and then and then
this the trans guy or girl I don't I
don't even know the verbiage can you
play that clip of the you're saying they
went from Miss Universe to miss the
point exactly and it's like I I remember
this video that that he's going to find
right now too it's like the Cockiness of
listen this is for women ran by trans
women and it's like like what who do you
think is going to get get on board with
this it's Miss Universe we want to see
real women like it just drives me
bananas it really does have you did you
find it Rob I found it if you ow me to
send it to your Rob did you use that
bananas thing as a metaphor here 100%
but it's like it's like when are people
going to wake up it's not working it's
not working with that it's not working
with send it it's not working in the
whole Sports thing and then by by the
way did you see Kim Kardashian now was
the man of the year for did you see that
which country had the beauty contest
with like GQ named Kim Kardashian Man of
the Year are you joking not no that's
got to be a joke no Rob can you put Kim
Kardashian Man of the Year you think I'm
joking it was on the Kim Kardashian is
gq's Man of the Year what are we talking
about yeah what is actually going is
this real life this is real life like
you can't make this up it's like at what
point have we got into where guy is that
a Babylon B article no that's GQ that
was GQ wasn't it Rob where'd you get
that story what the that was from CNN
CNN she's man of the year but look on
the cover of GQ I thought it was an
absolute joke she was wearing a tie she
was kind of pretending to wear a suit
guys we're we're sending 50 things to
Rob let Rob do his job Rob can you first
pull up the the video of the lady of the
the guy yeah go play that first let's
play now G what the Kim so confused
right now so's the world look May okay
there you go and and go back a little
bit go forward
organization it's a man baby from now on
it's going to be ran by women women
owned by trans woman for all women what
the H yeah yeah we're all going to lose
money soon we're going
bankrupt look at the boobs on that guy
around the world to celebrate the power
of feminism the miss okay God okay but
hey you got to give hold on you got to
go to go to the Kim Kardashian GQ thing
now if you could oh my like this is like
by the way you know you know what would
have been the best thing she could have
done turning it down yeah the best thing
she could have done is to say I'm not
accepting this award because I'm not a
man I'm a woman I've had kids are you
talking about Mana the read the article
Rob can we read this real quick the
recent the reality star entrepreneur has
been named gq's Man of the Year she
announced on in kashian Grace is the
Magazine's cover she's specifically
Tycoon of the Year posing with a tie and
a back Cheetos that was a picture I was
talking about she's joined by momer
Chris Jenner and sisters Courtney and
Chloe for the interview which covered a
wide range of topics from her skims
business the family late father Rober
Kardashian real life there's the cover
right there I was talking about yeah man
of the year Man of the Year issue Kim
Kardashian theover how are you trying to
confuse these young people that are you
know how many girls follow her and
worship her worship her and when they
don't even care about her claim for fame
was B and Ray J and her mother basically
selling and picking uh wi tape that they
were going to use bro that's right for
Man of the Year her uh her her
heterosexual activity has been fully
documented yeah and nothing drives me
crazy Adam when I hear people especially
girls that are like I don't care what
you say about her and how she got her
Fame you got to respect her business I
go no no I don't have to respect
because at one point I feel bad for her
kids who they're probably at the age and
hour they could get on their phones and
Google and find out like what their
mother did to become who she is it's
disgusting bro really but say what you
want about those trans women those Thai
trans they go for the Gusto bro have you
seen did you see that dude Ty lady boys
Tha lady boys you know is there
something you want to say no but did you
see the boobs on that guy see the Weir
on that lady by the way let me let me
Tom were you going to say something yeah
I the point here is they turn to the
trans they turn to the woke they turned
to this and then they turned into a ex
company in bankruptcy because they can't
get support they can't get TV viewership
I'm sure there's a woke TV executive
that'll give them a broadcast contract
however they have to sell ads against
that and make it profitable here's what
I'd want to do someone's going someone's
going to buy this let me tell you what
I'd want to do here's what I am actually
open to okay if this is a $20 million
company that she bought it for and it's
in bankruptcy right now I'm willing to
buy Miss Universe okay and I'm going to
go up there opening if we do this on TV
to give the speech and say moving
forward this brand misses univers we're
going to highlight the most feminine
beautiful wom genetically a woman period
that is the only way you qualify for
this we have to respect what women are
capable of doing that men can't do men
can't have babies men can't carry for 40
weeks women can carry women have kids we
have to give them the respect and the
love that they have the ability for
women to be feminine is what makes
attractive men attracted to them that
feminine side the gentle side the part
that gives us confidence we have to
recognize that I would be very open Tom
can you make a note Tom just take a look
at toy talk to the bankruptcy attorney
WR see what it looks like let's make the
phone call on seeing what it looks like
I would be very open for buying the Miss
Universe brand go ahead final thought
and by the way you're not getting
anywhere near Miss Universe do it so I
can't you're going to stay here and do
SAU so me wearing a dress and coming rob
you have that video what's funny I was
actually invited to go down to El
Salvador I swear to God my buddy sent me
a video he's like s this is what you're
Miss you'll see the video but actually
did an entire episode on sast earlier
this week on Miss Universe going broke
and basically why they went bankrupt
essentially you spend all your monies on
you know women who are not Honeys you're
going to go broke go woke go broke but
the winner of the pageant so there's 90
contestants the first time that there's
TR two
trans men women or whatever they are
called in the pageant okay I sent you on
WhatsApp Rob but the the winner actually
will will take home
$250,000 so that's what the winner get
so there's the high likelihood at this
point because you saw that Miss
Netherlands who's competing was a man
she's the one he's the one that won Miss
Netherlands so there's a high likelihood
that the winner will walk away who was a
guy there's a high likelihood that the
winner will walk away with at least six
figures and potentially six inches of
what's going on here here's the video of
my buddy like you should have come to oh
my come these are all women oh thank God
but see if you can identify the man I
that was him that just walked by I think
see if you can identify the men these
are the women my buddy sent me this this
is footage Mikey B if you're watching
thank you for this video my god look how
beautiful should have gone yeah you
trying to trick us cuz one of these
alphabetical order it might be a dud no
you you'll recognize the one in the
mustache and the beard you'll hold on
Camaroon beautiful how much longer I
don't know it goes on pretty long the
point is
these are they're very beautiful it's
amazing women but it's it's really
here's my final point when that trans
person gets up there and gives a speech
and the whole crowd is like yes of
course unfortunately women are complicit
in this you just saw the outrage we had
as four men who just found out that Kim
Kardashian is the man of the year and
we're just like no yeah we're
disagreeing with this we are
disagreeable unfortunately most women
aren't disagreeable like this and
they're just going to like yeah of
course
of course that man should be the woman
of the year that's the difference here
so I think that it's incumbent on women
to say uhuh we want a woman to win Miss
Universe not a born got be straight up
man it's got to be all chicks no
dimwits I know what you were going you
about to say it but it's all good okay
Tom why don't we talk about something
light uh not a heavy story like music
mogle Shan Diddy comes suit for rape sex
trafficking Jesus by singer uh Cassie um
which was his I believe right if I'm not
misten sing Cass in a level L civil
lawsuit has accused music and fashional
Diddy of rape and sex trafficking during
their decade long romantic relationship
with the lawsuit outlines disturbing
details of abuse including allegations
of rape Cassis suit claims that in 20
2005 when she was 19 years old the 37y
old comes lured the singer into a
professional relationship by singing her
signing her to her label Bad Boy Records
within years introduced her into a
sexual relationship and introduced her
to a lifestyle of excessive alcohol and
substance abuse and required her to
protocol procure elicit prescriptions to
satisfy his own addictions the suit
alleges the suit also claims that Combs
raped Cassie in her home after she tried
to leave him and it detailed other
instances of physical abuse and cson uh
uh uh during their relationship okay so
you hear a story like this Adam what are
you thinking with the story I mean stop
it okay look I've heard a lot of rumors
about Diddy he lives in Miami I know
people did a party with him but let's
get real here this was his girl uh for
forever I don't know if you could find
out how long they were together years
okay 10 years they're together you know
he cohered her with drugs and alcohol
and signing to the label now if he
literally full-on raped her zero excuse
for that but at what point here is this
just
absolute just tarnishing this guy's
Legacy and just going after we saw what
happened with John Depp the whole
believe all women is a sham so let's let
the facts play out you know this the
he's going to have attorneys he's going
to have lawyers I don't know exactly
what happened but at this point in my
life I'm not inclined just to believe
accusations on anybody the Russell Brand
thing I think is nonsense you know how I
feel about Andrew Tate I think it's
nonsense the whole Johnny Depp thing is
nonsense now you're going after Diddy I
think it's sort of nonsensical so but
what what do you think her motive is
behind it Adam for all all the time but
I mean she has she hasn't had a hit in
20 years who who's her isn't she with uh
Russell Wilson that's who Cassie is no
no no no you're thinking of
carara a beautiful different girl but
she's rich though she has money I don't
think so Doone she had that one song me
and you that whole deal whatever what's
her net worth Rob $8 million she ain't
got it like that where he's basically a
billionaire I'm pretty I'm listen I
wouldn't put it past him doing some
crazy stuff and like you said about the
stories I I'm shocked that it was a girl
cuz the the major ma of the stories that
I've been hearing about Diddy are him
and homosexual Behavior a lot hold on a
lot of them and I lived in Los Angeles
that's all you hear is is rumors like
that well if you read this article uh it
says that coms forced Mis venturer to
engage in sex acts with male sex workers
while masturbating and filming the
encounters so he's having other men come
over and have sex with her in front of
him F so go going to my point exactly
and it's like bro listen and like you
said Adam I'm not a a advocate of
believe all women wom but I do believe
that when there's smoke there's fire and
guess what I've heard so I'm from New
York bro I've heard so much about this
guy and what he's done and from his past
to what he's doing right now and it's
it's kind of it's kind of disturbing so
you don't know Tom how bad was Diddy
when he used to party with them how bad
Tom yeah it it was rough 3:00 a.m. I'm
calling rber I'm trying to be designated
driver I'm doing everything I can you
know and I'm calling snoop snoop we just
got to bring this guy down he said man
what he take so would go through what he
was on and you know trying to get him to
come down I think this is this is just
those delayed celebrity divorces
girlfriends need money things happen and
I think this is just a delayed alimony
for a girl that was in a relationship
with a guy and her career didn't go
where she wants it so now she's looping
back to see if she can get a delayed Al
she's been riding Diddy's Cil since 2005
just hear me hear me out on this I feel
that's what you're kind of saying yeah
hear me out on this she's alleging that
in
2005 hear me out we're in what year 2023
it's about to be 2024 that in 2005 didy
did dot dot dot dot dot yeah you didn't
want to come out in the last 20 years
basically all of a sudden this is the
time to bring this lawsuit this is why
this is BS to me you've had almost 20
years to come up with this 20 years and
all of a sudden you felt comfortable to
do it whatever goes on in the bedroom
with Diddy and girls I don't give a
it's like what did Judge Joe Brown said
the other day whatever do in your
bedroom get your freak on get your freak
on I don't really give a what
whatever he's doing okay I think it's
kind of weird but there's nothing
illegal about that yeah at some point
she need to take some ownership that
like all right this seems like a
Shakedown this seem like always follow
the money there's the word delayed
celebrity Shake Mez 303 UD man he just
gifted 20 members a pbd podcast
membership anyways so so yeah I mean
look there's there's this Jada Will
Smith thing going on the story with you
know what happened with Will are you
following that story as well and she's
reacting she said they're going to sue
her assist uh Charlamagne the god well
no there's a new story no the new one is
Will Smith's assistant is on a podcast
with a female I'm pretty sure Rob's
going to find it and mind you he's
spitting whatever he's say he's saying
it's the truth I don't know why he would
go public with it but he he said he's on
set Pat and in Hollywood it was hurry up
and wait and we and Pat you know that
they they rush you but you sit down and
wait and and he alleges that he walked
in cuz he had the key to his dressing
room here let's just have him say before
I just send oh you have it go ahead and
play it go ahead is this the killing
everybody want it and a music stop it
yeah we can't do it so here I'll send
you the video I find it do you want me
to set kind of set up something for you
rob or do we want to just watch it see
if this is the one with sound as
well yeah we can't I saw the same clip
so there's a there's a couple other ones
is this
it they have all the song So if you got
music go ahead just tell the story so
well basically this is this is Will
Smith's assistant and he said that uh
while they're on a movie set either the
director or the producer was scrambling
and they were like where's will get will
right now so he's going to he's looking
for will he can't find him he has the
key to his dressing room all right it's
locked he opens it and walks in and
Dwayne Martin allegedly has Will Smith
bent over a couch and by this guy's
verbiage he is murdering him he was yo
killing him I like I just want to know
that moment where Will Smith is just
like starting causing trouble in my
neighborhood he's like get out of here
what are you doing so and by the way and
Adam and you know my attitude it's
always like this if you you're get in
one little fight your mom gets scared
it's I'm move my but Adam here's my
thing any time this type of thing
happens and I get it's allegations we're
going to be suing you know what I would
do if I was the parties involved I take
a li I pay 400 bucks I take a lie
detector test and guess what it didn't
happen it'll never happen because
there's rumors how much stuff have you
heard about this guy have you heard a
lot of rumors P about Will Smith Rob I
sent you the uh video without without uh
music the one you sent has music pull up
the pull up the one with Fox the the
story that just came out that uh yeah so
Will Will Smith and Jada pinket deny
ridiculous claim that he slept with
Dwayne Martin planning legal action and
they're going to sue ah listen I've
heard a lot of crazy stuff about Will
Smith and this all goes into the their
relationship and their problem with her
and her sleeping with other dudes and
and son's friends and it's like bro it's
Hollywood and like you just said Adam I
don't care but you're going after the
guy because he's just tell he's just
telling a story of what he winess why
would that guy make that up yeah I look
whether it happened or didn't happen
again nothing illegal uh it's weird um
especially but I think the bigger story
here is has there been a bigger Fall
From Grace than anybody than Will Smith
nope okay it started with the Oscar slap
then it was the red table talk and then
the embarrassment of her his his wife
Jada publicly saying that she slept with
his son then she comes out with sorry
his son's friend sorry son's friend
there's so much stories I can't
keep up son's friend son's friend
Hollywood not Arkansas
yeah and then and then culminating with
yeah by the way he likes to just get
whatever each his own but but my point
is this there's people you look at like
Sam bankman freed you're like you're
just a scumbag dude or Bernie made off
what's worse what's worse fall him or
Kevin spacy Will Smith and it's not even
close Kevin spy is not in Will Smith
leag never has been well wait a wait a
minute Kevin spacy is Academy Award
winner nobody gives a no but no no
but but here's the thing though when it
comes to Kevin spy I think the
difference is America's sweetheart
basically is Will Smith Kevin spacy by
the way Dodges Ranger that guy is
Untouchable he's been Untouchable and he
can literally get away with you still
put will ahead of Kevin Spacey as the
biggest fall it's Will
Smith without a doubt you go and a
thousand people do you know Will Smith a
thousand people will know will you go a
thous a thousand people Kevin spy maybe
50% don't know who they don't everybody
knows you're talking about hang on hang
on you're talking about popularity right
yes correct specifically what I am
talking about yeah okay well let me I'll
go I'll go talk about something in in
parallel to that so take a look at what
happened Kevin spy lost his entire
livelihood he was dead radioactive
Untouchable did not work a lot of this
has been you know actually PR that's
kept will sort of in the news he hasn't
gone to zero work he hasn't had somebody
say oh that's so bad that you don't work
anymore nobody has said that to Will
Smith they've said this is crazy you're
slapping what are you doing it's it's
nuts it's bad behavior it's weird it's
tabloid fodder but it's not the end of
your career Kevin spacy's career came to
an end there may be more people that
know who will is versus Kevin but if
you're asking a fall from grace and
you're going to measure it on the
precipice of of popularity and Q ratings
okay Will Smith but if you're going to
take a look at what happened Kevin spacy
lost his entire livelihood off the air
yeah but by the way his his Q score okay
his Q score dropped from 3 which is a
great score to 24 is how bad Will
Smith's Q score Dr just after the slap
and that's not even including where he's
at today it's probably lower now about
Kevin space's Q score and what while
Pat's looking Adam and I'm with you
because think about it since that slap
and everything have you seen Will Smith
anywhere any move I he did the alad
movie then he did he did the King
Richard and that's you know that's when
he won the Oscar for I'm saying since
then Will Smith is not doing anything I
think I think the biggest thing with
will is that he's done nothing illegal
okay when you see Harvey Weinstein
illegal stuff okay when you see Stan
bankman fre illegal stuff I'm sure we
can name Morey
wasw Smith hasn't done anything legal
it's just like shameful everybody
everybody loved Will Smith yep okay
whether it's fresh prins or men in black
or uh Independence Day or Wild Wild West
the the new I can go on and on about the
movies and now you just look at Will
Smith and you're like come on bro like
Fresh Prince dog like what are
you doing only one thing he can do that
that's going to fix that he needs to
leave Jada yeah it's just one thing that
re to be done but it's never going to
happen B but maybe one of the reasons
that it's of 100% I was just going to
say it and Adam the reason for the
reason for this whole Will Smith J hert
cheating maybe guess what what if he is
a gay man and it's not working in a
relationship because she he's gay and
he's getting banged and guess what it is
what it is but who gives you it's
their relationship
gay I gay he goes hey yeahor from he he
plays in the back okay
along I think quite selfishly I Love
Will Smith I think he's awesome dude
like what if he's G Ali are you kidding
me like now I'm thinking of movies It's
just sad to see this is where he's at
that it's sort of culminating with yeah
by the way he's getting killed in the
dressing room murdered murder but hey
maybe that's what he that's what he has
to do to get into character that's not
that's each his own bro maybe he's like
Hey listen I'm going to get beat up in
the ring I got to get beat up in the in
the dressing room in the other ring in
the rim go let's go let's go to the next
Above the Rim let's go to the next story
here so we got Soccer Star Megan rapone
rapino a respect for that come on Pat
lady man claims injury in a championship
game is proof God doesn't exist Rob can
you pull up this clip she has a clip
that she stayed this post game interview
if you if you just go on Twitter you
should be able to find where she's
saying um prove God doesn't exit Meg you
just type in Megan whatever you'll see
her explaining this uh let me see if I
can find it myself so yeah if you just
type in it should come up Rob if it
doesn't come up in an interview that's
it right that that's it right there the
bottom a little bit lower Rob Rob right
there that's
her she's talking about her injury when
she tore her Achilles see this is a long
one although I'm I'm G to get the Aaron
Rogers treatment whatever that is um for
so I'm going to be calling him or
whoever did his surgery because we to
speed this up but yeah I thought about a
little bit I mean you know I'm not a
religious person or anything and if
there was a god like this is proof that
there isn't wow this yeah look at the
girl next oh it's funny it's
funny you see how uncomfortable the girl
on the right is oh she's just laughing
to laugh yeah but that's the problem
what are you laughing at what's funny
pat first of all anybody that has their
hair a different color all the time to
me it's like you're begging she's
begging for attention that's not your
every single time by the way she mind
you she's proom and she's fighting for
women's rights and everything but guess
what she is she's Pro trans she's proen
competing with with women and for you to
think like like she thinks she's special
what God can't have it's it's God's
fault that you're an aging athlete that
hurt your Achilles playing soccer like
what does God have to do with any of
dumb thing to say man what a dumb thing
to say there's called free will they
didn't tell you to play sports you know
how many people have had their achilles
torn and and Kobe went through it and
then Kobe afterwards like God is good
God is good God is good God is good and
he's the epitome of a guy that overcame
challenges and you sound like a little
pansy with the way you're reacting to
that and you you're what you're somebody
girls should look up to you're it's an
embarrassment on the way you handle a a
a a challenge and you blame God for you
playing a sport that comes with a risk
go ahead Tom you have any thoughts on
this Fant fantastic oh yeah it's I think
if you just yeah I'm going to go Ben
Shapiro a little bit here but I think
you know what I mean let's just go to
the pure logic of the
statement the the full logic of the
statement goes like this this proves God
doesn't exists and I would back up into
logic really what have you been doing
for God that maybe he turned his back on
you you've already said there's no God
and you've gone on these things and you
say you're not a religious person here
and in other places so how is this
something that you don't believe in that
you don't care about you don't want
anything to do with suddenly that this
this shows that that which you already
say doesn't exist doesn't exist there's
no logic in the statement there's no
logic in the statement whatsoever oh so
God who you don't care about if he did
exist and you say he doesn't is supposed
to be blessing you with athletic ability
deep into your 40s when you have an
aging athlete injury the lack of logic
here is Stupify yeah I I'll add this I I
have no problem with someone not being
prog good I do have a problem with some
being anti-god okay we had the
conversation with Judge Joe Brown the
other day and basically said that the
lgbtqia a plus cult is what he called it
has become a religion and you
know he basically gave
the metaphor that you can't have a cross
Crescent Moon Jewish star they're not
going to put that up on the White House
but they'll put a gay flag on there mhm
okay like you can promote lgbtq a all
you want in schools but you can't
promote religion so there's something
off in the country right now where the
lgbtqa is sort of Untouchable and they
can just basically openly bash God but
if you're like I actually believe in God
and I'm actually a Christian or I'm
actually a Jew or I'm actually a Muslim
and this is what I believe in you're
almost shamed for bringing your religion
to the table and I get the separation of
church and state but if lgbtqia is your
philosophy is your religion that too
should be a separation of church and
state so there's something off here so
that's my opinion on this no everybody
wants the state to stick up for their
belief system of course just remember
that there is no separation of church
and state everybody wants a state to
either step step up defend be smch or
smash your opposition so let's let's all
be honest that the everybody that says
separation of church to State it's they
want separation of the other guys church
and state yeah it's it's but great
points by both of you uh let's talk
about Elon
Musk uh Elon Musk does this on a tweet
Rob if you can pull that up so there's a
tweet going on this this guy here the
artist formerly known as Eric tweets
okay Jewish communities have been
pushing the exact kind of di dialectal
dialectical hatred against whites that
they claim to want people to stop using
against them I'm deeply disinterested in
giving the tiniest now about
Western Jewish populations coming to the
disturbing Rob if you can click to show
more uh coming to the disturbing uh
where is it there coming to uh where's
it at roing realization disturbing
realization that those hordes of
minorities that support flooding their
country don't exactly like them too much
you want truth set to your face there it
is Elon Musk you have said the actual
truth and that caused a ton of Mayhem
okay Facebook Co co-founder calls on El
mus to resign after Tesla CEO calls
anti-semitic tweet the actual tweet
that's one of the stories there's many
more of these that's going to come up
here in a second so uh uh that one the
guy is a a a pretty heavy duty guy uh on
I think he's a$ 20 billion guy I call on
El mus to resign he later emphasized
that musk should resign from everything
this call came from musk Andor forcing
an anti-semitic post by stating you have
said the actual in response to musk
support for anti-semitic comment there
was a Swift and widespread backlash
Tesla investor Rob Gerber revealed
getting a flood of messages from clients
wanting out of Tesla and anything to do
with Elon Musk musk is promoting hate
and CNN anchor Jake Tapper noted musk
was pushing unvarnished anti-Semitism at
a time of rising
anti-Semitism
and violence against to Jews a top Tesla
investor said he plans to ditch his
model y for a rivan after Elon Musk
agreed with anti-semitic post this is
another one here okay sadly this is a
win for rivan I will be replacing my
Tesla Model y for rivan next year and
I'm sure the rest of La will as well get
in C that's one Elon Musk boasts
anti-semitic tweet claims ADL and other
groups Push anti-white Messaging IBM M
pulls ads from X after Elon musk's inci
inary comment over white pride this is
from MarketWatch IBM States IBM has zero
tolerance for hate speech and
discrimination and we have immediately
suspended all advertising on X while we
investigate this entirely unacceptable
situation okay here's another one you
have said okay IBM has suspend a
following next to post supporting Adolf
Hitler and the Nazi party that's kind of
how they're breaking it down so anyways
I can tell you more and more I'm just
going to stop right there Tom when you
see something like this what do you
think about you know every CEO is the
face of the brand whether you're Richard
Branson and there a lot of people that
were flipped out be because you were
kite surfing they had naked girl on your
back it turns out her and her boyfriend
wanted the picture you know you have to
remember you are the chief PR officer
and you are embodiment of the brand um
when Larry Ellison buys all that land in
Hawaii and and then made some flippant
comments about what he was going to do
it's my Island I can do what I want with
it and certain people you know take that
and get get all upset you know they flip
out this this is those elements on super
duper steroids on the exact issue that
is a lightning rod in the middle of
society right now and Elon Musk I think
was careless you have said actual truth
I want to know where he was what time it
was
what was he thinking when he just puts a
response because his response he needs
to understand is a megaphone for
everything that he's invested in and
everything he believes in and if he goes
offline they're going for all of it and
this is the wrong if there was something
in that guy's tweet that Elon mus saw
that says hey you make a point here but
there's this and there's a balanced resp
response that doesn't happen but you
have said actual truth this is just hey
man you're CEO and you're leading and
you've got this out there you you got to
be careful and Elon Musk is a guy who
just says what's on his mind can I ask
you a question what what was that guy
actually saying in his tweet what was
the actual point Pat that what what what
is he's saying because I've been hearing
a lot of stuff from Charlie Kirk and
everybody about you know the Jewish
community and how they were anti-white
and you know Pro BLM and pushing and
hating what what is he actually saying
in that tweet can we break it down yeah
that's what I was going to ask you what
is he
he's saying it look at the first
sentence there that's that's not it is
it uh down well that so the initial
tweet that Elon replied to was a reply
to another tweet so this is the initial
tweet up at the top by hiding behind the
anonymity of the internet and posting
Hitler was right you got something you
want to say why don't you just say it to
our faces so here's what he said the
Jewish communities pushing exact kind of
dialectical hatred against whites what
he's saying is they've been pushing you
know the the anti- everyone else but
people forget that the Jewish
communities are sitting there supporting
Israel which is on attack from all sides
so he's trying he's trying to say that
the Jewish people are just as monolithic
about their side and against everybody
else um a and then B I don't really care
about it because now it's coming back on
them and they don't like it too much so
he's trying to say that the Jews are as
monolithically um you know
self-promoting and therefore racist
against others that's what he's trying
to say but he's leaving out the fact
that they're living on this little tiny
piece of property is being attacked on
all sides throughout history so to
protect yourself and to promote yourself
there's something else that's going on
in there and I think he made a
cumbersome point there and mus goes you
have said the actual truth as if this is
the Constitution or Magna Carta and now
everybody exploded um if I can Mo in a
little bit um number one Elon Musk has
been feuding with the ADL for quite some
time now okay months uh months if not
longer than that whatever their Feud is
publicly hot months well you know
whether Twitter has become more racist
or more anti-semitic or more woke
whatever it is he has made the platform
a free speech platform that's the sad
thing about free speech is you're going
to find out some that you don't
pretty much agree with or want to hear
but that's sort of the price you pay for
free speech and I'm totally okay with
that so I don't know his personal beef
with the ADL um as a Jewish person look
I've heard wild conspiracies about Jews
I've never heard in my life that we're
anti-white th this is completely new to
me so whatever this whole nonsensical
argument is just it just doesn't make
sense to me like Vinnie asked what does
it mean Tom tried to explain it I don't
really get it I like I don't get it but
that's besides the point here's where
I'm at with the on musk you know Ronald
Reagan famously said someone that you
agree with 80% of the time is not 20%
your enemy they're 80% your ally dude I
like Elon I think he's awesome I think
he's doing things great for Humanity
great for society but occasionally he
does some dumbass like it's
probably not good for him as a CO's the
company to be smoking weed on Joe Rogan
would I smoke weed with Joe Rogan and
Elon Musk you better believe it that's
probably not good for the stock price
though you know is is this probably good
for him to be weighing in on these types
of very hot button issues does that help
Tesla does that help SpaceX does that
help your brand I'm imagining right now
Linda yako who's the CEO current CEO
she's doing the whole Joe Biden Anthony
blinkin thing like no what are you doing
she's in her office do she's doing the
exact same thing that blink did when
Biden called she a dictator like dude
why even do this why invite this
nonsense like let's make some freaking
money by the way IBM not a small little
company not a small budget is this the
type of company you want just basically
pulling their advertising money and I
get that there's an element of Elon Musk
famously he says I don't care I was just
going to say that what's quoting the The
Princess Bride but at some point there
needs to be a delicate balance of like
just don't shoot ourselves in the
footage does there does there Adam when
you're when you're like cuz I'm I'm with
you like what's the motive where he
doesn't care and you're like hey make
that money he has all
the world then don't hire a CEO don't
try to be
profitable Twitter is hemorrhaging money
right now and basically you're saying
like why can't we get our together
this might be one of the reasons again I
like Elon mus it's just not the best
let's let's do this Rob can you show the
clip that I just sent you if he can show
the clip I just sent to you uh right
there if you just show the clip okay
listen to this and here is logic go
ahead I mean you really have if if
you're not going to just
outright commit genocide like against an
entire people which obviously would not
be acceptable to to really shouldn't be
acceptable to anyone um then you you're
going to leave basically a lot of people
alive who subsequently you know hate
Israel so really the question is like
how for for every Hamas member that you
kill how many did you create mhm that's
that's a very good question you create
more than you killed you've not
succeeded that's the you know the real
situation there that's a very good
question and it's safe to say that if
you
know
um if you know if you kill somebody's
child in
Gaza you you you've made at least a few
uh Hamas members who will
die just to kill an Israeli and by by
the way you can pause that I agree with
them I lived in Iran that hatred is real
because of what they did to them years
ago and it stays and it doesn't go away
by the way guess who has a very strong
belief in that both Israelis and
Palestine and Muslims now both sides are
also right and wrong one can entertain
both ideas one side is talking about
cleansing Muslims are saying you know
Israel is doing a cleansing
cleansing can you pull up Muslim
population uh uh growth history can you
pull that up Muslim population growth if
you can just pull that up and go okay uh
uh uh yeah okay right there look at that
1970 577 million 2000 1.29 billion go
three rows down if you can click on yeah
three rows down if you go low oh sh okay
yeah right there there you go zoom in
okay 2020 two billion where's 2023
population can you type in 2023 and by
the way in 1800 was only 91 million so
if you type in 2023 Muslim population
what do you find it's got to be like 2.1
billion billi so they went from 500
million in 1970 which is only 50 years
ago they have 4X okay now meanwhile go
do the same thing Rob go to Christian
population growth history Okay Christian
population growth history and let's look
at this one here uh uh if you look at
Christian population by decades if they
can have the same kind of a chart as
they do on the other one that'd be when
you're finding it I look forward to Jew
as well and then Pat why why why while
you're looking for that are they talking
about the cleansing just there though in
that one region but but it but no
they're talking about they're talking
about that that could be the argument as
well so here you go according to P1
research 2.2 billion Christians around
the world up from 600 million in 1910
600 million in 1910 I would love to know
how many Muslims were around in 1910 can
you pull that up total Muslims
population in
1910 okay population in 1910 all right
so if you go Muslim population in 1910
will it show it I love to see uh uh
religions in the world 1910 to okay
perfect go on that one because that's
all the religions in the world makes it
easier all of them are on the same page
uh is it a video Let's see if there oh
there you go zoom in look at Miss Muslim
was 221 million Christians were 61
million they were 35% Muslim was only
12% fast forward to today
Christianity is is 2.2 billion that's
2010 by the way today Muslim Rel Islam
is 2 billion little over 2 billion
they're having babies they're having
babies and they're growing now go do
Jewish population okay Jewish population
growth history something like that if
you type and see what comes up and
here's what you'll notice it's 15
million people man yeah it's not a lot
of so zoom in a little bit because of
the Holocaust the number had been
reduced to 11 million by the end of 1945
the population grew to around 30 million
by 1970 and today they're at around what
15 million 16 million is where they're
at today so so you're talking 2 billion
2.2 billion versus 16 million this means
for every uh uh Vinnie to just kind of
put that in perspective for every uh a
thousand uh Muslims that get for every
10 Jews that get killed it's the
equivalent of 1,400 Muslims getting
killed got it did you get the math there
okay so now so so that cleansing is it
doesn't fit in this narrative now go to
Israel on the other side when they're
talking about you know you know here's
what we have to do you know go get them
you know Ben Netanyahu go get him Nikki
Haley you go do eliminate this this that
okay all right bro relax uh uh if you go
with that one you know the guys that are
being interviewed and Pierce Morgan last
night how many Palestinians have you
killed such and such 11,000 11,000,000
how many of those 11,000 were Hamas he's
they're saying a couple dozen meaning 60
to 80 only 60 to 80 H that doesn't make
any sense well then that's why I think
that's where the cleansing P it it's
it's for that it's for that region yeah
so so to me that that makes no sense so
Elan is right what he says for every
child you kill in Gaza you're producing
future Hamas members what else are you
going to live for you're you're going to
seek Vengeance the rest of your life and
I know you just hosted a debate between
lummer and Dave Smith yeah for Zero
Hedge a couple days ago they called us
and we said Adam would be a great fit
you
know when you're having things like this
happen you know it it makes for tensions
to be up and Elon makes the comment that
he makes there and then a market wants
to come out and react to the way they do
Elon has the right to say that but guess
what just like people stop drinking but
wiser and people didn't like the fact
that anheiser bush send a couple beers
to Dylan Mulan the same standards should
be held to Elon Musk no matter how much
I love Elon Musk the same standard
should be held to him if IBM wants to do
that because they're like hey man we
don't like what you're doing this is
this is not cool man do you understand
the cleansing happened to us they were
trying to cleanse us the Jews the
Israelis that is exact that word is
Scary For Us yours is 4X in the last 50
years we're we're not forx but we're
only grown 20% in the last 50 years if
that is what we've grown so that's the
part where there is a there's a lot of U
you know uh contradictions on both sides
and a lot of truths being said by both
sides but do you blame anybody on one
side taking their own side and not
wanting to see behind you know past
their own faults it's such a horrible
horrible situation it's it's it's not
pretty man but no I don't I don't I
understand why businesses decided to cut
from Elon Musk there's a risk to freedom
of speech and one of them is I don't
want to sponsor with you anymore yeah um
the the term ethnic cleansing that was a
term that I learned when I was a kid
because I had to learn about the
Holocaust and this is a term that
actually I think is near and dear to our
hearts because the term genocide and
Holocaust has happened to both of our
people The Armenian Assyrians The
Armenian Genocide Syrian genocide um
that was in 1915 I want to say Obviously
the Holocaust where 6 million plus Jews
were were killed um listen uh Jewish
Christian Muslim uh the killing of
civilians is never right period full
stop you know so I hosted this debate
with Dave Smith and Lauren lumer both
Jews by the way and it was interesting
three Jewish people having this deep
deep discussion totally different
opinions and I'm moderating I'm my job
is to listen and learn and really Host
this discussion you know they talked
about the esic cleansing thing but
according to uh World data population
between 1990 and 2020 2 the Palestinian
population has gone from 1.9 million to
5 million I'll repeat that in the last
30 years it's gone from 1.9 million to 5
million that doesn't sound like ethnic
cleansing to me it's 1 55% increase in
the last 32 years just to be specific
and in Gaza it's expected to go from in
the city of Gaza before this war was
expected to go from 645,000 to 2.1
million by by 2040 so the term ethic
cing is just so not applicable here now
what I will say to my friends in Israel
gentlemen BB
Netanyahu um the world is watching okay
big time uh we get it you're literally
fighting
terrorists you're fighting Hamas that
was elected in 2005 20 2006 after the
disengagement after Israel pulled out
and now you're fighting terrorist and
there was an emotional reaction but the
world is watching I would argue that now
after this event sponsored by Iran who
is basically the the greatest champion
of Terror in the region which you you
just interviewed the Sha he he called
them what a mafia like regime and
basically the business model is chaos
they seow chaos everywhere they fund
Hamas they fund Hezbollah they fund the
houthis that's going on in Yemen this is
a business model but Israel the world is
watching and I would argue that Israel
is now less safe than it was among and a
half ago there's no question about that
and the final point is this is is I had
a conversation uh about this obviously
with Dave and Laura here's what needs to
happen if for this ever to take if
somebody H held your kids hostage your
kids hostage don't you think you would
have somewhat of an emotional reaction
obvious they need to figure out the ha
situation the Qatar Saudi Egypt Jordan
they need to come to the table get these
hostages figured out they need to
develop a rebuilding plan for Gaza they
need to hold elections again and they
need to acknowledge whether it's the PA
whether it's fata whoever Hamas can no
longer be leading Gaza they're a
terrorist organization like seriously
and then the hopes when this when Gaza
when the Palestinian people which have
inherited billions and billions and
billions of dollars from the
International Community and they've been
funnel in hamas's war
chest look at what Dubai did look at
what the UAE did okay look at Abu
Dhabi Palestine Gaza is a beautiful
place it's on the Mediterranean it could
be just like Tel Aviv if you take that
money you invested in education
infrastructure your people hospitals
schools and educate rather than
indoctrinate there's a day in time in a
generation or so Generations Go 25 30
years where Gaza can ultimately maybe be
Dubai but you actually want to have to
have that happen and not and have love
and peace and prosperity and GDP and not
Terrior
and and then here's the flip side though
Pat it's like have you guys been seeing
what's happening in the streets all over
the world protesting at the capital
they're like you have to ask a question
of why are all these people guys it's in
the millions that they're upset the guy
that was on yesterday Pat with Pierce
Morgan and the and the Jewish guy uh
they were asking for numbers so schie
let's just say the number of Innocents
that have died in Gaza it's around
10,000 and and they ask Tom how many of
Hamas and they're saying a couple of
dozen or the number let's say 60 Hamas
so at that rate you're killing one Hamas
for
300 uh innocent women and children right
so at that rate you'd have to kill 3
million Palestinians to get rid of Hamas
so that's you have to ask the question
is that worth it and that's why the
outrage is happening in the street uh
and then you have to think about this
too why is someone like George Soros who
is Jewish funding all those Pro
Palestinian all these people in the
streets I don't get how that type of
person is involved for this but you have
to understand and you nailed at him at
what point do you have to say okay guys
time out because that ethnic cleansing
that you're talking about it's not the
whole group of Muslims it's for that
area everybody's going bye-bye if your
goal no it's not I just give you the
numbers not everybody at this yes it's
sad there's 10,000 people but Hamas is
holding them hostage I Hold On second
but but my point is tactically if the
goal is Hamas Adam because that's the
goal nobody's going to argue the goal is
to get rid of Hamas all right but at the
price of getting rid of all these
innocent women and children that's where
that conversation has to happen because
guess what it's not happening right now
nobody is saying all right guys it
happened October what date was it
October October 7th anger pissed off we
want to retaliate I get it but right now
it's almost a month we're getting a like
okay let me ask you one question
yeah uh they've Israel the IDF has
basically said get from the north to the
South we're coming yeah okay if someone
told you hey Vinnie get the hell out of
this building go to the other building
cuz we're coming you would leave uh
who's holding the people of Gaza hostage
is it Israel that's saying you can't
leave or is it Hamas basically shooting
them and killing them if they try to
well here's here's one of my things
where are they going to go when you when
there's a refugee camp Pat had to go to
a refugee camp when he left
Iran some people Adam some people mind
you and I'm I'm thinking I'm thinking of
the people there cuz I'm not there some
people are like I don't want to effing
leave cuz if I leave I'm never going to
be able to come back so that's what Adam
come back to what to come back to to
their land that's they that's they but
meaning so you're burnt down house so
you're broken down like but listen I'm
not I'm not saying that this is right
but Israel is basically saying we're
coming after Hamas
we're eliminating these terot tunnels
get out of here by the way I Reuben
posted this Rob I just want to show you
the clip on this guy's talking and then
you know uh I've seen this it's
disgusting go ahead and play this clip
watch this year go ahead he said America
First you weren't happy with that Li
Israel would not exist without America
so know America First for you no are you
an American yes and you don't want to
put America First no the idea that
Israel would not ex me yeah to me I have
I I have
zero uh uh uh tolerance for that for
what she's saying zero tolerance for
that and she's wearing a m she's
covering her face that shows you what
type of I don't I don't care what she's
wearing on her face that's not what I
have any problem with do that I'm I'm
used to that I lived in Iran 10 years I
saw that every day I'm I'm immune to
that I don't care about that your words
you're in our house this is America it's
a house that we're all living in if you
don't like the house you're living in
get out y period there's zero tolerance
if you're if you don't like what America
is then get out and go and live
somewhere else yeah go to Canada go to
Gaza if you want to go to you know
somewhere else but don't don't be here
entertaining those ideas of you hating
your country get out if you don't like
what America stands for that that's the
one part where I draw the line and I
have no I don't have any kind of a
tolerance just to be clear I wasn't I
wasn't talking about the hijab I think
she's just covering her face so she's
not seen saying like that that's
what I I wasn't saying about her a job
it it I think it was just a scarf for
some so let's let's go to this next one
here which is kind of weird Americans
express support for Osama B Laden after
reading viral letter okay so Rob if you
if you have this I think you have a
couple of the clips a 21-year-old letter
penned by Osama B Laden the founder of
Al Qaeda alqaeda gained viral attention
on Tik Tok leading to Osama Bin Laden
support for the terrorist leader the
letter known for its openly anti-semitic
language was originally published in the
guardian in 2002 was removed from the
platform on November 15
2023 after the trend became widely known
the letter itself contains explicit
anti-semitic content and justifies the
September 11 attacks by Lan blame on
Jewish people Ben Laden's word include
statements such as your former president
warned you previously about the
devastating Jewish control of capital
and about a day that would come when it
would enslave you and the United States
shall pay for its arrogance with blood
of Christians and their funds okay can
you show a couple of those CPS uh Clips
Rob if you got it uh uh I you showed it
earlier so I'm sure you have it right
there if you want to just these are Tik
Tok influencers
[Music]
this that's what Rob that's showing
clips of she's the biggest culture shock
coming to the Western world because you
had to leave our country uh from the
white terrorists that came over and
killed and bombed millions of us years
and finding out that we were terrorists
in the west world because one of the
event was clearly plotted by the
American government she basically saying
9911 uh was was set up and then you know
they caused this terrorist attack so
then they went over there and they're
causing Terror so now it's their
responsibility to come here and do
terrorist yeah to us my
interpretation is that her entire life
she moved to the United States to be
free she comes here hears that the
people from her own Homeland are deemed
terrorists but then she looks at what
she came to the United States to flee
which was the terrorism that the United
States puts in other countries okay yeah
so so okay fantastic no problem if if
that's the case you lose the argument
with purely data and FYI I'm not one
that's sitting here saying 911 was 100%
this and there was no Insight we
interviewed the guy that came in here
and sat down for two hours and the
interview was taken we were flagged for
it so we'll entertain those
conversations and I'm not sitting here
saying who owned the building you know
the person that owned the building all
these other weird things that we're not
going to get into right now but here's
what I'm going to get into simple data
you came here your family came here you
feel safe here Muslims come to Christian
countries to live because they feel
safer here why do Muslims come to
America how many Christians move to
Muslim countries how many Jews move to
Muslim countries how many Catholics move
to Muslim countries why not not tell me
why not does America have a a a a track
record where we've had presidents here
and there that they've used the weapons
of mass destruction or the you know
military-industrial complex that I
talked about that be careful with have
they used it yes yes people have used it
of course they've used it and how could
you say that so comfortably because
that's money is tempting for certain
people and some people can be bought
some people have their dirty stories
comes out and they use that against them
for 40 years so that never leaks to
anybody because they don't want to be
publicly embarrassed that happens in
politics that happens in sports that
happens in one of the questions I asked
the Sha was one of the Sha's son Crown
Prince R pal I asked him about a general
called fust who was the deputy director
of saak and this General deputy director
of savak Fardo was a uh uh the
right-hand guy to the shot this guy
right here and he was was so poor
growing up but his grandfather Sha's
grandfather meaning Rea Pal's father
reah Khan paid for his son to go to
France to get educated and paid for him
as well to go accompany his son fast
forward years later there's rumors that
this guy had a a gay lover a general
abos and this guy goes from being a
deputy director to of Sak to being the
deputy director of savam fori why would
keep you because they had dirt on you
yep and that's how they kept your
loyalty and they say we never release it
to anybody so they kept it and they used
is that possible for that to happen yes
are they think that things happen in
politics that's sty yes but data tells
us this the restaurant that people feel
the safest to go and raise a family in
regardless of your religion is America
that's where people feel the safest in
till today it could change tomorrow it
could change if Americans forget about
data and forget about why people come
here you want to find out what Detroit
looks like you want to go to Michigan
you would think you're in the Middle
East go to Detroit go to Michigan
they're totally safe it's America
America allows you to be here whatever
religion you are to live in a place like
this so they can talk about all these
letters and have the Vengeance and it
was an inside job and I'm glad we did
this and da all this stuff you want to
say you go at it you say that all you
want it's not going to change the fact
that America is the greatest country in
the
world and our job of Americans living
here who believe that is to call out
when we are going in the wrong
direction and call out data that proves
that we are the greatest country show
economical advancement and Technologies
what we've done that's positively
impacted everybody and then hold the
leaders accountable to not continue to
mess that they're doing like our current
president today that he's given a speech
and saying what is true that g is a
communist is a dictator and his own Camp
looks at him shaking their head saying
you should have never said that yeah we
can't be transparent here so yeah we're
going to do the accountability thing but
no you can't make the argument about
America is a country you're not proud of
so Tom what are your thoughts when
you're hearing these stories about Osama
Bin Laden letters and what they're doing
about America well I I see two things
first of all a point that we made
earlier in the podcast if you go back
and look at the US war in Afghanistan
Iraq and there were women and children
that were killed and we can look back
and we can see now there are populations
there that were the children that were
born out of that and they're worse than
their dads were and so the first truth
is you know it all comes around full
circle the second truth is you know the
price of freedom of speech is freedom of
spe is free speech and I agree if you
come here and you have such a problem
and I think Jimmy Carter was even
interrupted
um during a speech and someone screaming
screaming screaming and I think he just
said very simply okay you can go
back and it was a a clear point and and
I think that when people are are Jimmy
Carter said that I think it was Carter I
think it was Carter was interrupted in a
speech by someone protesting about
something and he's like you can go back
you know it's like you know the doors
open the other way or something but it
was he was he he said it in a nice way
like if things are so terrible here why
why don't you go back but um I I agree
with you on one key point about the data
this is a one-way Street America is
where everybody wants to come so they
can have the Free Speech but when they
come here and they don't want to at
least respect
the foundation that gives him that free
speech I got a problem with that so you
come here so you can pop off your mouth
you know without consequence you take
all those gays for Hamas yeah go do that
little demonstration in Beirut see how
that demonstration ends you better call
the cop first to encircle you because
you're going to need protection before
it starts you're going to be Bas jumping
from the top of a building the issues
that I have is exactly what you
have but I never want to give up free
speech and it just kills me that these
people are here but one of the prices of
free speech is Free Speech Y and the
beauty though Tom with free speech you
get to actually know what's inside
people's Souls that's the beauty of Free
Speech cuz we get to see what we are
dealing with for those that come here
and immediately don't like it here you
want to go back go back but it is a
one-way Street people don't like the
hell hole they're at they want to get to
the United States and unless they're
from Venezuela end up in Chicago anyway
I want to go back to Venezuela real
quick you know be for a lot of good
reasons you know it's just like really
it's so good here that you can pop off
your mouth you can do what you want say
what you want be what you want and all
this and it's so good here and then you
cross a line when you want to tear down
what is here because there's no logic in
that where's the logic in that that when
you get here to express yourself freely
and you're not going to be bonked on the
head and but then cross the line over to
say this place sucks it should be torn
down wait a minute the reason it's here
and exists like this is the reason
you're here hey p p p what did your mom
say when she was watching TV and someone
was giving an opinion about the US
president and it was translated for her
oh God they're going to kill him and how
long has she been here just first week
exactly right so she's watching TV and
she's seeing here with her perspectives
from not in the US she's a guy doing
this it gets what's he saying translate
it for me blah BL blah blah blah oh the
poor man they're going to kill him
because that's her reality from where
she came
from the price of free speech is Free
Speech but when you cross a line you
want to tear it down you
know I want to send you back well I'll
I'll kind of put a ribbon on this we
started the whole conversation off with
basically Tik Tok right so what's the
biggest who owns Tik Tok B dance China
CCP so Pat one of the things that you've
educated me on and you've educated our
audience is things need to go both ways
right so we can have Tik Tok here let us
know when we can have Facebook Instagram
YouTube let us all have all our social
media apps in your country all right but
you can come do whatever you want here
you can steal our IP all right great
what does that have to do with the
situation going on in the Middle East
let's only fans to the Arabic countries
yeah I'm sure Mia Khalifa would not last
long in Gaza right now doing all that
but there is something at the core I
think look people say Islam is a
religion of peace and I'll take them at
their word amazing I have friends who
are Arab Islam Muslim great zero beef
whatsoever friends but we also have to
admit that there is a faction if it's 1%
that's 2 million people if it's 10% it's
20 million people okay 200 million
people that are islamists
fundamentalists uh and want to practice
fundamental Islamic Sharia law export
basically the caliph
internally and externally and want to
practice Jihad that is an element
of Islam that needs to be addressed and
I'm not saying that's all or even most
but if it's 1% or even 10% of two
billion of two billion people what's 10%
of two 200 million people that's a
that's conservative number so if it's 1%
that's 20 million people that's
1% of islamists fundamentalists are more
than any Jews on the planet let's just
establish that so you could go to any
country you want you're in Dearborn
Michigan you're in La you're even doing
riots in Miami you're in London you're
taking over London you're in Paris
that's awesome you're exporting your
beliefs that's awesome because these
countries these democracies will take
anybody but much like China you can't go
to Iran you can't go to Lebanon you
can't go to Syria you can't go to Gaza
with any other belief other than theirs
yep so if you want to come into the
Western world into the Jo
judeo-christian Democratic world and
have your beliefs and set up your areas
do your thing we have people of congress
that are basically supporting supporting
Hamas it's actually acceptable here but
you can't go to that side of the world
and try to say yeah I'm a proud Jew I'm
a proud Christian this is what I'm
trying to do n so it doesn't work both
ways and there is a douber standard and
that's the problem that I have exactly
what works in durka duraan isn't going
to work let's go to the next story all
right a couple things here so uh one
177,000 signed petition against Macy's
Thanksgiving trans
Extravaganza um nearly 17,000 signed
this petition organized by 1 million
moms in a conservative group affiliated
with the American Family Association
decrying the inclusion of two-gender
non-conforming performers Justin David
Sullivan and Alex n in the upcoming Macy
Thanksgiving Day Parade the petition uh
claims that the event will promote a
liberal lgbtq agenda that is not
familyfriendly 1 million moms warns
Macy's the parade sponsor against
associating with trans performers citing
past backlash and boycotts facing by
corporations like budl or for similar
partnership the petition criticized
Macy's for its involvement stating it is
clear that Macy's does not have our
children's best interest in mind Tom
thoughts on this Beware of the crowd the
people are speaking up people are less
worried about this Council culture and
now people are speaking up and saying
listen if you want to make the the
Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade has been
a parade forever for everybody and if
they're going to you know in you know
inject this this this wokeism and
promote and feature these performers
then guess what the customer has the
right to say Hang on we're all together
here and we don't like that and you know
better be careful we've got wallets and
Black Friday comes right after
Thanksgiving and you know we're we're
not into this and so I I think the
consumer is people let's put it this way
people now that we know what happened
with Co now that we understand what's
happened you know with George Floyd now
that we understand what's happened with
so many things some of the good and the
awareness that was inside some of these
protests and things that came out the
other side is being exposed and how
people are unafraid to speak up against
it they were so scared during Co I can't
speak up against it I'll lose my job it
those all this and all of a sudden we've
got apologies going to US servicemen
whoops sorry hang on you know back you
know Gosh guys and now I think people
are unafraid to come up and speak their
mind and so the consumer is speaking up
and I I think this is this is the way it
should be the consumer speaking up you
want to put it out there consumer
doesn't want to buy it and they want to
protest that's a right can I go into
that one p because because and Tom it's
crazy me I was just telling Pat that I
wanted to go there you just brought it
up about the servicemen so uh and about
covid and the vaccine the US Army is
sending letters and I I sent rob a photo
to former troops saying that in light of
the removal of the covid-19 vaccine
requirement they uh cannot apply to to
get their reasons of discharge change
this means derogatory remarks or
dishonorable discharges can now be
removed or reversed notice notice how
how weird that is right they're also
inviting unvaccinated uh people to join
because recruitment numbers are down so
all of a sudden they stop their vaccine
requirements right but not before
forcing thousands of solders to get the
J just like our friend Pat major Katie
Hernandez she's a really good a friend
of our she's done my podcast she now
suffers from my carditis okay now those
soldiers should be able to Sue and
that's the letter that Rob uh has up
right now and it's like Pat all this
like you just nailed it she should get
her VA benefits so she doesn't go broke
on that I think 100% she just she she
just got stationed uh somewhere else she
was here on the show but it's like now
really now you're telling them like Hey
listen that dishonorable discharge that
mind you and Pat you know this it ruins
your life Adam if you have dishonorable
discharge at on your record that is
nobody's looking at you bro that means
the government doesn't trust you so now
what you're going to reverse it now
after you've already ruined my life F
you to the government for doing that
type of to these people and and
speaking of Pat like I'm going to stay
on the vaccine uh uh vaccine topic while
I was going down this Rabbit Hole I
started seeing videos and some of these
articles about something that you never
hear about and it's the Amish community
uh when it comes to the unvaccinated
like their their children because our
our numbers for for autism and add and
all these chronic illnesses are sky
rcking in the Amish community the
percentage of their children having all
these diseases at them is very very low
almost even non-existent and it's like
our government our government has been
studying the Amish people for decades
Tom but you know why none of these come
out to the public cuz it would destroy
the CDC and all their narratives about
forcing all these drugs on our kids it's
crazy that you never we you think of
Amish and people are like look at those
weird look at those weirdos but you know
what those weirdos as children are not
dealing with the that our kids are
dealing with because they haven't been
forced all this poison narratives hate
sustained data perfect segue to my point
and um look um am I trying to go Amish
on you no but listen one of the great
honors of being on this podcast since
dbd started this in 2020 is learning
right I've been wrong on some things
I've been right on some things but I've
learned a lot and one of the biggest
things that I've learned uh is the the
need for traditional family values in
America okay the the nuclear family two
parent household and understanding what
makes the world work and what makes
relationships work and what raises kids
the right way and watching how Pat
Raised his kids and watching how Tom
raised his kids like Vinnie you and I
we've been pretty selfish right you've
been focused on your stand-up comedy
career I've focused on making money
doing everything with that partying in
South Beach but you know there tons of
time in a man life whether he's 30 40 50
whatever the freaking number where you
realize all right there's more to life
than just having a good time and party
and and telling jokes and all that and I
do want a family one day you know I'm
dealing with some different women out
there I get it we're honing in trans
women or just just regular old old
school women gotta but I I I I I all my
best friends are married 99% of them I
assume most of your best I'm Uncle Adam
to all these kids I have a nephew like I
I want to have a family and it scares
the hell out of me to see that this is
what parents have to worry about these
lgbtq a plus woke transgender this is
what kids are being indoctrinated with
and it's scary as hell and injected with
and injected with as well of course
forcing forcing something inside of them
so you know you famously I quote it all
the time whether someone should be
selfish or self selfless and if you're a
young person out there and you don't
have a family you don't have kids you
should be mostly selfish make your money
do your thing look your best feel your
best act your best but once you have
you're married and have kids you have to
be way more selfless right 100% And it's
just very scary to see what's going on
out there and uh I understand why
parents are freaking out and I
understand why this is such a hot button
issue I would not want my kid dealing
with the nonsense that's going on today
I'm glad these service people are going
to get some leave cuz normally a U-turn
like this from government only happens
an election year and at least it's not
oh oh wait oh wait yeah but so Pat being
because this is an article of of the
army you were in the Army how do you
feel that they're doing this now to
these PE to these thousands of people
Pat you were in I was in how how do you
respond to something like that you're
getting a letter now saying hey what my
bad Rob go back to that ad the the one
that says no vaccines to join the
military whatever ad you had zoom in a
little bit this is what the recruitments
are putting out exactly so look at this
US Army covid vaccine not required
career opportunities over 150 jobs up to
$50,000 of establishment enlistment
bonus full-time part-time guaranteed uh
uh 1918 pay per month starting for
officers 36 37 over $770,000 for college
4,000 in tuition assistant guaranteed
job for choice no 2 3 4 5 six year uh uh
enlistment options 100% College tuition
travel the world 30 days paid vacation
army training and course count towards
your college degree so can you imagine
how embarrassing it is to not have to
say vaccine is not required the lead
story now they say don't bury the lead
that's the number one thing by the US
Army embarrassing that they have to say
some like this
now for them to call back the other guys
and say hey come back this happens that
part is normal Elon Musk fired 50% of
the company and then he realized oh
we fired some of the people we needed
yeah and they're like listen can you
come back I we need you can you come
back and some of them came back someone
said screw you I'm not coming back this
happens everywhere um the Army made a
mistake the military made a mistake and
it the the people that were forced out
and were publicly humiliated we had a
guy on here that was forced out after 14
years and we had him talking two years
ago how he felt what he was feeling like
it was emotional this is all you know
you want to do 20 30 years in the middle
if you had 14 years you know what you
want to do six more years to get your r
retirement you're trying to get your 20-
year retirement you're trying to get to
your 25 30 year retirement but uh I'm
not surprised bad ideas keep getting
exposed it's continuous the only thing I
ask is we need accountability and for
people to not have a short memory when
they try to do this again that's the
biggest part again the next time be loud
you saw what they did don't sit on the
sidelines and say you should take it if
you don't take it you don't care about
the elderly people you don't care about
your parents and your grandparents what
if your grandma died what if your mom
died what if you this died and they
would put this fear in everybody and uh
it was a very weird time anyways we are
at the end of the podcast uh really good
podcast Lots coming out stay tuned gang
for the Pod that'll come out most likely
tomorrow the interview with Crown Prince
Resa palavi uh Town Hall uh if you
haven't picked up a ticket yet for
General Mastermind General uh seating
this the last opportunity someone of you
guys are going to get a chance to post
questions at RFK and some of you will be
walking up if you're part of the VIP
you'll walk up in front of RFK you'll
ask the question he'll address it and
many of those clips last time went viral
and were picked up by other people this
is not an event you want to miss uh
especially for a man with that kind of a
last name RFK go to 5990 live.com to get
your ticket again go to 5990 live.com to
get your tickets we will see you there
December 6th in for laud take care
everybody bye- bye bye-bye